i got to ask you  what is a man i'm sorry what is a man  i do politics not dictionary are you a  man  i think so and  what is the man  you have to get a dictionary you know  the male thing right but a man what is  this what you do define words  yeah what is the man i don't do  definitions on my show i'm not the right  person to add that's so boring do you  know what it is do i know what a man is  when i hear the word man i think of  mankind like homo sapiens and you know  what's the future of mankind well don't  feel badly if you don't know what a man  is because a lot of males don't know  what a man is okay you know so you're  not alone in this one okay and these are  some good males don't know what a man is  i gotta ask uh love what is love i i  don't do dictionary definitions you  don't no so you do you know what love is  ah i think you know love when you see it  and  and what is it when you see it  you just know it you can't even put it  into words it's so ethereal  amazing